[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talk about whatever we want and
this is a special yeah yes oh my god
guys Joe Joe's been Joe's been gone for
a bear mascot Joe's I have mice fogging
up my glasses I've been gone for almost
a month were you worried you and you get
trapped over there forever well yeah I
mean first in Europe was nuts dude but
you know what's crazy is that Austria is
pretty much back to normal I heard now
no really they didn't recover fast wuhan
opened up yesterday
yeah well this waste work than that we
are here yeah it was it was way quicker
because well Austria shares a border
with Italy so when Italy was going crazy
they immediately closed the border and
then I wasn't I was at Germany too so an
hour like into the train ride we were
just on you were checking the news and
then they announced that Germany closed
its border and we weren't even supposed
to leave that day we were just kind of
like we got it we should just go to
Austria right now yeah like donating
mass yeah thanks thanks for yeah okay
I'll tell you exactly since I've been
back it's been over three weeks so
almost a month yeah oh yeah that means I
haven't seen you guys in over my oh yeah
he's been alone yeah the only the only
like social contact that I've had was
pretty much like the few minutes when I
grab the masks and in the few minutes
that I have with like medical pros or
whatever sometimes I just give him my
address and they'll come pick it up on
my doorstep because I know they're not
gonna like famboy you just leave it in
the middle of the driveway yeah
literally just on my doorstep or
how that even started though okay so let
me uh I've been quarantined so I'm okay
so evolving quarantine I mean how many
days have we all been quarantined three
weeks three weeks
twenty-one well today would have been 21
but now it resets cuz I went outside my
house and I saw you guys wait you've
been literally like in the house but if
it was your son quarantine but if your
quarantine and then you meet other
fellow quarantine people aren't you
still coordinate rumor so and Kevin
doesn't count like you reset so our
count reset sitting I maintain the six
feet distance no matter what during this
whole time so even though I did meet
medical professionals I never went
inside the hospitals or clinics I would
be in the what do you call it the
parking lot and then I'll open up my
Gras I mean my [ __ ] a trunk yeah and
I'll be like here you go
so how it started is my buddy Joey
shoutouts to Joey he's a he's a good
friend of mine for many many years from
raving to he became a very successful
guy in the video game industry and so
you know I had a ton of lemons so like
like literal lemons right and I'm all
like who wants some lemons right cuz
that's making this tree it's huge it's
[ __ ] massive dude I produced ten full
grocery bags and I could probably
produce four more to have some one tree
I mean yes one no just one big-ass tree
and so he has he has two daughters and
they'd like his wife always makes juice
right so he's like hey can I get a bag
and I'm like you gonna have two bag bro
so he gets it and I was like what you've
been up to cuz like he's always working
so he's like oh man it's crazy the
hospitals need our help and all this
stuff and he starts telling me this
story where he supplied a couple of
these masks to some of his friends who
work at hospitals and in word got around
and then he started to figure out what
was happening so there was a supply
issue for all PPEs meaning like personal
protective equipment right and we don't
really know this as civilians because
what
happening in the hospitals is well for
one there's a [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] in
a supply chain China makes everything so
that's why when China got sick they
weren't producing right and then when I
ran Europe everybody else got sick
before us they had to buy all the stock
so China needed stock so did Europe so
then the American hospitals we didn't
prepare for this [ __ ]
and like the the other thing is that the
American hospitals were what we use is a
lot of people are wondering why we don't
have supply and it's because we reduce
something called just-in-time logistics
and then it all started with the car
industry but they realize that you make
more money and you save more money when
you don't have a whole warehouse full of
supplies and so what they'll do is over
the years they like they do some math
right and they figure out generally this
is how many people will get sick
annually and over over the years they
know like how many all flu season is
coming around we should order about a
thousand masks or whatever they need
right but no one prepared for one no
supplies in stock and two people being
this [ __ ] sick and worldwide to
actually cut back them the supply in the
past a year or two because of the
tariffs so hospitals have been cutting
back on how much they need to hold on
hand yeah because the Tara stick just
cost so much to import it terrorists
terrible you know what else is crazy to
a nice to work at the hospital I used to
see like an insane insane amount of
waste like so much waste like so okay
they had these carts like these
isolation cards when someone has to be
like quarantined and but then when when
hospital workers go in they have to wear
their PPE and like these yellow gowns
all these gloves everything every single
thing that's in that cart that it even
if buses haven't been opened and [ __ ]
they still throw it out just because it
was in that cart so it was a they don't
consider the cardboard box like
contamination proof no oh yeah like they
still may not know everything you know
how bad it is it's like so that's what
you're supposed to do standard wise and
standard wise
as soon as you see a patient you're
supposed to redo everything yeah they
don't have enough supplies they'd have
to use one [ __ ] mass the whole day
the whole day so a lot of people are
like you need to give them in 95s and
I'm like you guys don't even [ __ ]
know right now like right now this is
good quality and this is like a
three-ply or something like they're
getting one ply like you know how your
cousin was telling me like I gave a
Bart's cousin's girlfriend and their
whole bunch of friends a bunch of these
national works out of hospital yeah they
work at a home they were just having a
party but here's what they were telling
me is that the hospitals are providing
really chat like cheap not even standard
FDA masks they just don't have supply
and so it's gotten to the point where
some hospitals especially the
underfunded or the the you know like the
in lower communities or whatever right
like they don't have like the support
that major hospitals do and it kind of
sucks because what what's happening
there is like they have to stop surgery
they have to stop doing certain things
because they don't have equipment and so
so they're saying like people literally
like are at life and death and it's not
because they have the Rona's it's
because there's no supplies so people
who need to get surgery right now
they can't even operate yeah we had a
friend that worked at a Cedar sinai and
he got laid off because they're like we
just can't give you work and then he was
like they basically cut all the the
surgeries that were non like
life-threatening what does that person
do closer I'm playing the pilot he's a
he's an EMT oh yeah so he brought
patients in and so he's important yeah
but then uh they're like if someone
needed to get surgery right now because
of like diabetes and take the leg off
they're like we have to we have to wait
like two months yep yeah I know they're
pushing back anything like cuz they're
non-essential even in terms of medical
so like if you had a colonoscopy planned
it's all canceled yeah my cousin still
does what I used to do and she said like
luckily for her the last time I spoke to
her she's still able to have work but
her clinic specifically is like not not
a trauma clinic or anything like that so
like she's just like yeah luckily I
don't know how but I still have
right now because they're still doing
non-emergency surgeries so I like that's
what people don't know either - that
hospitals they make the bulk of their
money doing the extra surgeries or the
most complicated surgeries they don't
make that much as like just wouldn't
sick people come in like regular stuff
yeah they make the most on the high like
like high insurance specialty stuff yeah
and like plastic surgery all this other
stuff right and another thing is like
people don't know that there's so much
like red tape and politics involved in
hospitals - like they have to get from
this list of suppliers like I even know
that people that work in hospitals are
saying don't send to the administrators
and don't just drop it off at the
hospital know they're hoarding it hmm or
they're thrown away like because it's
not standard or whatever barding for one
reason they need a ration and then so
like you'll get one of these masks for
the whole entire day so what we've been
doing is giving it direct to nurses and
and what they'll do is they'll just pass
it to their friends hey yeah that's what
they're calm they're being confiscated
but then like they can't do anything if
you're like a healthcare professional
you bring it from home right and then
you give it to your friends that's
different from like Hospital regulations
so hospitals have to follow their own
regulations which is like these masks
are not whatever you know literally
confiscated from these people that are
bringing out becomes available they're
not allowed to pass it out to them it's
like not on the public and there's a
paper trail you can't but then if you're
bringing your own personal stash it's
almost as if like I bring the sandwich
to work I know Nadine's hungry so I
split my sandwich with him even though I
know there's not enough food at the
cafeteria so technically I'm not
supposed to but it's like the reality is
he's hungry as [ __ ] and so I'm just
sharing food I know some hospitals were
getting in trouble because they would
say that not everyone can use a mask
right now involved some people would
bring their own masks and there would be
some nurses that would bring their own
masks in and then they would get in
trouble for bringing on masks and they
would actually get laid off
they report it to the news and then the
hospital in trouble and then they hire
back on the nurses added like you know
scare of PR and [ __ ] super super
particular because I remember like I
used to work as a like I used to
forgot the term ready but I would jump
from hospital patients no um was it
rotations
no not rotation oh my god per diem I was
pretty young so anyway um okay so some
hospitals they or mandatory that I use
the disposable hair hair net thing and
in other hospitals they allowed us to
buy our own and bring our own and like
wash our own [ __ ] yeah well I'm like if
100 do it like you're right it's just
something it's so much it all it takes
where I'm like this is ridiculous I
don't know nothing on different Hospital
is a business is what people don't
realize is like well even if it's County
funded it comes from the tech taxpayers
money and that's their business and each
hospital is its own brand but I think
people don't understand that so like if
you most people seek medical care
because it's a necessity so they just
think it's a necessary service but like
there's a difference between like a
kaiser permanente the county
cedars-sinai they're actually brands and
the brand of medicine that they serve is
all different and they have a different
culture for each Hospital and well I
spoke to a doctor right here at the
Royal bomb clinic or whatever it's like
an East LA and what he was saying is
well he has a great relationship with
his administrators but a lot of health
care professionals are afraid to speak
out because I'll be like hey can you
like take some photos or like can you
say something so just there's
transparency that we're sending these
masks out or whatever and a lot of them
were like well I don't really feel
comfortable because we're not supposed
to be doing this and then so a lot of
them are afraid of the backlash of
administrators because the hospital has
an image right and a lot of them don't
want to look like they need help because
they're like you have all this money
what's your problem and the problem is
it's not the money a lot of these
hospitals have money the problem is
there's no supply because even if they
want to buy it they can't get it so it's
like how do we get it right
it's we told retailers a coalition of
them to stop selling it to the public so
my friend is a
can boss dude because he has those kind
of connections where he could just phone
the CEOs of all these different
retailers it's almost like telling
Walmart hey uh Walmart can you not sell
your masks to people and we'll take them
over and we'll real people that meet
those people that are working that Nita
right now and but there are business too
and they need to eat and they need to do
this stuff to like feed their own
employees or whatever so it's crazy men
and and so what he's managed to do is
also team up with Minnie so which is the
guys that produced these masks too and
they matched our our donation so we got
about fifteen thousand in donation
within a week and then they they saw the
what we were doing and then dairy like
okay well we're gonna completely just
match what you guys make and I'm like
dude that's freaking dope so that's like
about twenty thousand masks that they're
giving us but it's it's crazy because
that's another thing too is like so
retailers they'll do they'll import
their own masks right but because
they're not in connection with hospitals
and [ __ ] like there's just all they
can't buy from them yeah they're not
direct distribution yeah and but what
the government is doing now is they're
just going out and anyone that has masks
in the warehouse is like they're buying
millions of that [ __ ] so that's that's
some other crazy [ __ ] that's going on I
heard that they even like say like a
whatever company was in America that was
making masks and like distributing to
the whole world like they came in and
was like yo you gotta stop it's only for
America you can't give it to anyone else
but Americans yeah yeah that's mr.
there's a lot of companies I've been
seeing too that they no longer produce
what they usually do and now they're
just creating PPE I for example Nike I
think is creating face shields damn
companies have switched over to creating
masks and face shields like tesla's has
been trying to do that do the
ventilators two ventilators yeah a lot
of like big companies are trying to help
out in any capacity they can for barbell
stuff like we have a lot of things made
like overseas like Pakistan or China or
just even parts and what's crazy is in
certain countries they're able to just
go straight to the manufacturer and tell
them what they're doing so we had these
shorts
developing and there's like not you guys
aren't making any shorts anymore you
guys are making PPE immediately which is
cool because the world needs it but it
was crazy that to see like how other
businesses can get affected by it
because the manufacturers can just be
told by the government what to do and in
solve I'm curious how have you guys been
spending your I know you have but how
are you guys been spending your days in
self quarantine I've been like thriving
I've been doing so good what have you
been doing I like to make [ __ ] a lot
like we know I you know all the gym
clothes I was like okay I need I need to
work out so then I I made my own like
squat rack not a welded [ __ ] yeah the
video coinies old worn out and bought a
welder I bought like a gas tank and
everything so I could like make like a
legit weld you can make a [ __ ] ton right
now if you build those things and sell
it yeah why what gym equipment is a hot
toy I built him and also down selling
out yeah yeah so I bought like
upholstery foam and stuff and I built
beach I bench cuz he need adventure he's
just betting on his uh on his coffee
table pictures of this yeah yeah yeah my
commission need to do something good
build me a squat rack
you made Apple boxes very well for
Christmas I did I did and then yes well
then yesterday I just finished building
my wait tree that goes on wheels and
everything wheels we have our own
blacksmith in the crew surprisingly
enough the wheels cost the majority of
it like metal is not that expensive and
like heavy duty metal and the whole tree
like without wheels are like under 20
bucks now I feel bad to say what I've
been spending all day long wake up going
the garage like making [ __ ] all the way
to night times don't like everyday do
gym that's another thing people are
doing what my hobby dream is everything
nothing's doing I'm just building [ __ ]
all the time like just building your
whole motorcycle from scratch getting to
like do woodworking like Mexican DNA's
like
I got a bill I know that's I was so
bummed once we actually saw how much
space we have in the new house there's
not enough for a workbench or like oh
like my own like utility space it's
always space somewhere like I make
everything foldable or on wheels so like
what's a nick offerman you know the guy
who plays Ron Swanson and stuff he's
like the thing to get started when
you're like interested in this [ __ ] is
like find one thing you want to make and
buy the tools you need to make them one
thing and then find one other project
and you slowly like build out what you
need that's tight so now I got like a
whole ass workshop I gotta come over
when this is all over can you make bongs
and stuff that's glass why can't you
wooden ball or metal bong do gym
equipment is crazy expensive now though
everything is double literally when I
ran out to get the barbell so this guy
was our key he was sending out all of
his [ __ ] right and he was like yeah one
of my other buddies wanted to come over
and well somebody else came over right
before you came he was trying to buy all
my [ __ ] and resell it in LA for like
five times the price nope that's what's
happened when he found out the guy was
doing that he's like no I'm not selling
to you anymore I'm talking to up to like
everybody else here for normal price
yeah yeah yeah it's crazy I don't even
know this order for five time yeah we're
buying so rude it was like people want
to buy that much but they just can't
find it business I bought a 200 dollar
set that you could get at Dick's
Sporting good it was like a like a like
about 200 pounds worth of weight right
in a bar for 770 oh my god you paid for
that yeah because I was desperate like I
can't I don't have weights I don't have
anything like I need to go I need to do
stuff how much was it supposed to be 200
200 round like 200 bucks yeah this is
that Dumbo that like it's basically one
set of dumbbells and you can change the
way you get it for like four years ago
oh so my homies ballin for 1500 what
that is not work
doesn't go ninety-five a lot of money
that's not worth that much probably
worth a couple hundred in real life
right me like reason on quarantine life
and there's people with Alex we actually
are yes so so at our outer gym at our
gym we have well a ton of equipment
obviously because it's a gym right and
then so when we shut down the gym
because that's what what the mayor
wanted a lot of our members they were
the first approach was like I think a
lot of people are really into fitness
they care more about losing their gains
and they do about like the whole Ronis
oh my god like they're like doing I know
you guys are gonna be walking down in
there man come on let me come in let me
come in and then we're like no we're
gonna follow the law no one's working
out and everyone's trying to beggin I
just have an extra please I know what
that everyone's everyone's like we're
like let them know like no we're not
having special treatment and then so the
next thing I guess to help our members
our gym manager came up with an ID like
what if we rent the equipment out and
since this is part of their home gym
they'll take care of it so they put out
an announcement on a newsletter and then
in one day all of it got rented out Wow
30 40 50 barbells and everyone's I need
one anyway your gym right now is like
ghosted of all equipment all the regular
stuff that's not specialty expensive
it's all done the expensive like
competition plates they're really we
can't afford for people someone I'm
messing up on a sidewalk yeah but all of
our normal equipment is all rented out
which is cool so people are still making
games at home you know what a [ __ ]
Asian I am I told this fool I was like
you better sell this [ __ ] right now for
five times and then when this is all
chill and you got to open up your
business back up you buy four normal
prices you buy it back yeah it's not
gonna go back down and then not
immediately and then we're just gonna be
out of business for hella long but after
I feel like after this dies down we're
out of quarantine after three or six
months people my sell other stuff cuz I
have my own home gym yeah and it's not
the same it's not the same my training
at a gym so like I had it and even I
sold my equipment to the gym cuz I was
like when you go to the gym the
environment is just way different so no
matter how much stuff you have
it just doesn't feel the same and your
ended up not using it I'm building a new
habit man
I think I want to build a garage last
time I've been enjoying a bump in the
music in my garage is dancing in between
sets pretty nice well I feel like it's
cuz you don't have it like like at your
house you're probably love me enough
because you got used to not having it
yeah but once you go back you'll I guess
this is the same because you had your
own hole if you guys want to help us out
if you guys want to help out the
hospitals and all that stuff check in
the link down below you can see we
surpassed our goal but we're gonna keep
going on because a lot of hospitals are
still in need of all the pppppp bees
[Music]
[Music]